democrats to include the media
continue to lick their wounds and
attempt to formulate some sort of
rationalization for their party's
overwhelming defeat on tuesday night
they've of course settled on the racial
answer as they always do which was
pretty easy because that's the answer to
every question that the leftist mind
might ask and as we discussed yesterday
was it was immediately decided that the
voters in virginia are all racist
which is why they voted against the
white man terry mcauliffe and for the
black female lieutenant governor win
some sears you know racism is funny that
way apparently
we played some clips on the on the of
the media connection fit yesterday but
grabian has put together a nice and
succinct compilation
uh so let's let's just take a trip down
memory lane and watch some of this again
glen younkin
played the race card for a reason
because he knows it works on certain
white voters he did stoke white
grievance politics to mobilize the
republican base he's laundered trump's
really sort of
disgusting flagrant out racism he's
wrapped it in education education right
which is code for
white parents don't like the idea of
teaching about race that's the
fundamental problem for these parents
and this anti-crt movement they don't
like the way whiteness is being
portrayed in these new more inclusive
lessons this wasn't about those
pocketbook issues this was about
how white kids feel talking about what
black kids go through the subtext of all
this was we can't let these black and
brown people run the country glenn
younkin running
on critical race theory that he knew hit
accord around race i think all the crt
stuff is trumped up dog whistling some
of it was
uh dog whistle racism the dog whistle
messaging that you saw younkin
engage in during the course of the
campaign
well a real diversity of opinion on
msnbc and cnn you got to give them that
at least
white grievance they say white identity
politics white anger white backlash
interestingly online um the blame has
been placed more specifically at the
feet of white women bigoted dirtbag
wajahat ali with the daily beast
published an article yesterday afternoon
titled you damn karens are killing
america
now i've long argued that karen is a
racial slur originally when i said that
people laughed at me for saying so
they're not laughing quite as much
anymore because the karen thing
as we see is not a light-hearted jab at
certain types of white women it has
become and indeed always was
a label that non-white people use to
describe any white woman they don't like
waj ali's article is nothing but a long
insult laden diatribe targeted at all
white women
he despises the entire group and is not
shy about saying so it's impossible to
imagine any white commentator using a
common black female name as a pejorative
and then writing an article with this
kind of tone and message this is a
treatment reserved for whites and
especially white women
and in fact it's downright tame
compared to what you find in less
mainstream corners of the internet for
example here's a viral video from some
random caucasia phobe i'm going to call
them now
again again letting white women know how
much he hates their guts and again
feeling perfectly comfortable saying all
of this out loud
dear white women what the [ __ ] is your
purpose huh what the [ __ ] is your
purpose huh what the [ __ ] is your
purpose other than ruining the
[ __ ] casserole what the [ __ ] is
your purpose other than voting against
your better interests what the [ __ ] is
your purpose other than running the
[ __ ] holes with expires closed
casts knowing what that's been expired
since 2010 talk about i want to speak to
your manager i want to buy something for
my timothy it should be silly good it
seems like every year white women just
keep getting worse aren't they getting
worse if you look at the electorate
white women continue to vote for
republicans every year it keeps going up
it keeps going up so my question is why
should we trust a lily white house white
women can't be trusted well no kenny
don't be so mean to them you know the
white suburban women are going to get it
together no you're not if you ain't got
it together then you ain't going to get
it together now y'all didn't even vote
for your own white sister hillary why
should we trust white women and the
thing that's really pissing me off is we
continue to call these white women while
we keep [ __ ] on black women we keep
[ __ ] on black voters but we always
put all this stock into white women that
are never gonna [ __ ] show up for us
that's continue to vote against their
own better interests
just can't imagine man i can't imagine
why um any white woman wouldn't want to
vote alongside that guy
it's a mystery
now the most common conservative
response to the claims of white
grievance and white backlash
is to deny them and insist that you know
race had nothing to do at all with the
results in virginia but that's not
really true and we shouldn't pretend
that it is now racism had nothing to do
with the results
but race itself
even white grievance and white backlash
quote unquote did indeed play a part and
rightfully so
the fact that white voters are
shy about admitting this only shows how
deeply ingrained anti-white racism has
become there shouldn't be anything
embarrassing or controversial about
saying out loud yeah i'm white and i
don't like anti-white racism and i will
vote against it
no member of any other race would
hesitate to admit that they find racism
targeted against them objectionable and
that they're motivated to take action
against those who display it
virginia was not merely about race the
broader issue was education but one of
the major things that voters in virginia
wanted to extricate from their school
system is anti-white racism specifically
anti-white racism and we need to be
specific about that
this is not racism in general that you
find
mainstream systemically in the school
system not racism in general it is
anti-white racism
not any other kind of racism anti-white
parents do not want their children to go
to school
and learn white guilt and self-loathing
yeah
that's correct
i have a grievance against that as a
white person i do
why shouldn't i
another viral tweet this from a woman
named morgan kilday says in an
accusatory tone it says
white women vote to protect their white
sons that's it
now she means this as a criticism
but that only shows how deeply embedded
is her own anti-white bigotry the left
as a whole is hopelessly lost in the fog
of its white-hating bigotry they can't
see
uh
up or down
that now they accuse white mothers
accuse white mothers
of wanting to protect their sons as
though this is somehow shameful as
though white mothers ought to respond no
no that's that's absurd i would never
dare protect my sons they're white after
all to hell with them
yes white mothers want to protect their
white sons
of course white mothers want to do that
just as black mothers want to protect
their sons and asian mothers want to
protect theirs and so on for all mothers
of all races and ethnicities
likewise white people in general want to
protect themselves and their families
from all forms of bigotry and hatred
that might be targeted at them
they are going to be less likely to come
stand by your side if you spew racial
insults and invective in their direction
the democrats have spent years shouting
into a bullhorn white people are evil
scum they're the source of all that's
wrong in the world die whitey die
then they look with shock and horror and
shake their heads in disappointment as
fewer white people line up to vote for
them
i mean they're sitting there with the
bull horn white people are terrible and
then white people walk away they say
what are you walking away for
oh you must be racist
the way they see it
white people do not have the right
to self-preservation period don't have
the right to it
we should not be motivated by any desire
to protect or defend ourselves in fact
we shouldn't even be using words like we
and our at all
that's the way they see it as a white
person to even say the word we
in reference to other white people
is controversial and provocative
it's a racist dog whistle
because we're not supposed to notice our
race
or have any sense of racial identity at
all
everybody else on earth can everybody
but not white people
the only time a white person is allowed
to notice their race
or of any sense of racial identity it's
an is in a strictly negative way so we
can look at our skin and say i am white
and i am ashamed
shame on me
but we cannot say
i am white
and i deserve to be treated with respect
and dignity that we're not allowed to
say
the latter thought process is deeply
troubling says the media it's
problematic
it really worries them
it worries them that there are some
white people out there who aren't ready
to to throw themselves into a fire
it's white grievance they say
well you're damn right it is we have a
grievance
and our grievance is against you
rabid foaming at the mouth bigots
we don't want to vote for your side if
it means we must bow in shame and
submission and we certainly don't want
you anywhere near our children
kids have enough identity crises forced
upon them by the culture already they
don't need racial self-loathing on top
of it
so white grievance white backlash short
absolutely well deserved
and we aren't the ones who owe an
apology here either
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated